at one of many different crime scenes
across several communities a search for
clues for a motive
for some answers
this is the home of wes peterson in his
late 70s he was stabbed inside while his
grandson hid in the cellar
his neighbors who know they could so
easily have been victims too
remembered a kind popular friend
i don't understand why they would target
someone like him anyway
because he was just a poor helpless
little man and
everybody cared about him because
that's the way he was he cared about
everybody else and they cared about him
the investigation into multiple
stabbings and the manhunt which followed
has been one of the biggest in canadian
police history it took a dramatic turn
late yesterday when one of the two
suspects was found dead the deceased is
damian sanderson
his body was located outdoors in a
heavily grassed area in proximity to a
house that was being examined
we can confirm he has visible injuries
these injuries are not believed to be
self-inflicted at this point
damien's brother miles sanderson remains
on the run police have now confirmed
that they have been looking for him
since may
he'd been released on probation from a
five-year sentence for assault and
robbery
it was at 5 40 on sunday morning when
the police received the first 9-1-1 call
the unfolding horror was soon clear with
multiple calls in minutes from over a
wide area
the province of saskatchewan lies in the
centre of canada the largely indigenous
communities targeted are small and
isolated from each other
the police identified 13 crime scenes at
several locations in the james smith
cree nation indigenous community and the
smaller village of weldon half an hour
drive to the south west
among the victims to be named lana head
a mother and a grandmother my thoughts
and the thoughts of all canadians are
with those who've lost loved ones
and with those who are injured
this kind of violence
or any kind of violence
has no place in our country the
investigation now has multiple strands
the manhunt and the motive are key some
victims appear to have been specifically
targeted
others were stabbed at random
it will take a lot for these communities
to begin to recover from such an
extraordinary series of attacks
mark stone sky news